hi Josiah welcome to Saint Louis it's
awesome to see here it's good to be here
so you're the wild card holder and then
you have been playing so many
tournaments like back to back for like a
year or something I don't even remember
since you joined Mrs Justin right yeah
and how does it feel to be here after so
much you know effort you put to gain
back your rating and getting your norms
I mean it's it feels great like
um I was mentioning at the beginning of
the year in January I was 2350 feed a
base got my my lowest point in the last
five years with zero norms and then I
was able to secure my first Norm in
February and honestly that was just kind
of the start of a great run now live I'm
2465 with two norms and playing the US
Juniors and then after this the World
Cup so definitely at the peak of my
chess career but hopefully that's not
the end well hopefully it's not the pick
right I was very glad to see if you come
back to 2400 or almost 24 50 and then
you qualified for the World Cup and then
you scored two gym norms
and what do you expect from yourself
this year in general well I mean I
definitely uh my expectation for The
Grandmaster title previously was to make
it before 21 which will be next August
um 2024 but with my recent insurgents
I'm hoping to get it by the end of the
year I have a few more normens lined up
and as you mentioned I'm playing pretty
much back to back sales
um so definitely GM by the end of the
year and uh hopefully you know I'm gonna
put together a good performance for
juniors as well as World Cup where I'm
playing my teammate I know right it's a
bummer yes I've been a bummer but you
know look how do you feel about that
um you know it's just like any other
opponent it's a bit unfortunate of
course that we have to be the ones to
not knock each other out whoever it is
but uh you know it is any other
opponents and uh you know of course
Misha is quite strong so it'll be a good
battle but it made uh it made it hard
for us to root for someone you know
right it's it's a little I'm like oh I I
wish I could root for you both guys but
I will do that hopefully it will break
some good games yeah exactly we'll do
that and then uh what's your
expectations of this tournament this
tournament I mean I'm hoping to win it
you know definitely it's my it's my last
Junior so probably my best shot at
qualifying for the US championships and
without the top three seeds playing this
year definitely it's uh you know I guess
a better opportunity for me even though
I'm going ninth out of tenth seed
um I'm only like 130 points behind the
the top seed so yeah anything can happen
and uh you know my lot my recent
tournaments kind of goes to show that I
can definitely put together some good
performances so I'm going for the going
for the title you already calculated
everything didn't you as usual I tend to
think about these things
that's great and last question do you
think changing sunny California to
called Missouri to join mizuchas was a
great decision I think it was a great
decision yeah I mean it's definitely uh
I don't like being away from home but
it's been a pretty short time thus far
and it's been great you know surrounding
myself with uh you know Gregory Misha
the other the other guys
um you know yourself just uh you know
training um with Christian and being
able to play all these tournaments it's
honestly been a great change of pace at
first it wasn't looking so hot and I
know Christian was definitely
disappointed my performances at first
but things have turned uh turned well
out well recently and so it's definitely
been a great decision for my chess for
sure I'm so glad to hear that yes and
it's recorded
that's awesome uh it's awesome to see
you here and I will be rooting for you
good luck at the tournament thank you
thank you
[Music]